Nos piden simplificar la raíz cúbica de 27
"a" cuadrada "b" elevada a la quinta "c" cúbica
y el objetivo
cuando estás extrayendo una raíz cúbica,
es analizar la expresión que tenemos
dentro el radical
y extraer de cada término
aquello que sea un cubo perfecto,
aquello que sea una expresión elevada a la potencia 3,
para poder extraer la raíz cúbica
de esos cubos perfectos,
sacarlos del radical y dejando dentro el radical lo que no sea cubo perfecto,
veamos qué podemos hacer
empecemos con 27,
quizá pueda reconocer que es un cubo perfecto,
pero de no ser así,
puedes descomponerlo en factores primos.
27 lo podemos escribir entonces como
3 por 9.
y 9 lo vamos a escribir como,
3 por 3,
así la factorización de 27 es
3 por 3 por 3,
27 es exactamente 3 al cubo,
vamos a reescribir entonces esta expresión aquí abajo,
en términos de cubos perfectos,
27 lo podemos escribir como,
3 elevado a la potencia 3
3 al cubo
"a" cuadrada
si hubiera sido "a" cúbica podríamos extraerlo,
pero "a" cuadrada no podemos extraerlo
de esta raíz cúbica,
así es que voy a ponerlo por acá...
podemos escribirlo en cualquier orden,
es un producto,
entonces voy a poner por acá "a" cuadrada¡
"b" a la quinta...
"b" a la quinta no es un cubo perfecto,
pero la podemos escribir como un cubo perfecto, multiplicado por algo que no es un cubo perfecto,
"b" a la quinta,
la podemos escribir como
"b" cúbica por "b" cuadrada,
si quieres ver explícitamente esto,
"b" quinta podemos escribirlo como,
"b" por "b" por "b" por "b" por "b",
cinco veces.
Estos primeros tres, son claramente "b" "cúbica"
y estos segundos 2 son "b" cuadrada,
entonces "b" a la quinta
lo podemos escribir como "b" cúbica,
"b" cúbica...
lo voy a hacer en el mismo color púrpura...
"b" cúbica y eso multiplicado por
"b" cuadrada,
no importa el orden como lo ponemos
pues estamos haciendo productos
y finalmente tenemos,
"c" cúbica...
lo va a hacer en azul...
que es claramente un cubo perfecto,
se ha elevado a la potencia
"c" cúbica lo ponemos aquí,
del lado de los cubos perfectos...
"c" cúbica
y todo esto bajo ese signo de radical,
estamos aún tomando
la raíz cúbica de todo esto,
y esto
aplicando propiedades de los exponentes,
o más bien aplicando
propiedades de los radicales,
es igual a...
bueno,
estamos con la raíz cúbica de un producto,
es lo mismo que primero saquemos la raíz cúbica
de cada uno de los términos,
y luego hagamos el producto,
ahora, podría tomar la raíz cúbica
de cada uno de los términos,
o podría tomar la raíz cúbica de
3 al cubo por "b" al cubo por "c" al cubo,
de hecho,
hagámoslo de las dos maneras,
así es que separando términos
¿qué tenemos?
Tenemos la raíz cúbica de 3 al cubo,
por la raíz cúbica,
de "b" cúbica,
voy a mantener el color...
dejamos el mismo color,
para que los identifiquemos,
por
la raíz cúbica...
de "c" cúbica...
la raíz cúbica de "c" cúbica,
y por estos términos no me voy a separar,
no podemos extraer una raíz cúbica de ellos,
así es que los voy a poner juntos
en un solo radical,
la raíz cúbica,
de "a" cuadrada,
voy a mantener los colores
para que podamos identificarlos...
de "a" cuadrada,
por
"b" cuadrada
y podría haber separado esto
como la raíz cúbica
de "a" cuadrada
por la raíz cúbica de "b" cuadrada
pero eso no va a simplificar más la expresión
y ahora analizando cada término por separado,
¿aquí qué tenemos?
la raíz cúbica,
de 3 al cubo,
la raíz cúbica de 27,
eso va a ser claramente
3...
3 al cubo,
la raíz cúbica de 3 al cubo es obvio que es 3,
¿aquí qué tenemos?
la raíz cúbica de "b" cúbica...
la raíz cúbica de "b" cúbica
es simplemente "b",
luego la raíz cúbica de "c" cúbica
esto es,
"c"
voy a ponerlo en el mismo azul...
vamos a usar el mismo azul
para poner esto, "c",
y ya hemos simplificado la expresión
esto es igual a 3
por "b"
por "c"
por la raíz cúbica de
"a" cuadrada "b" cuadrada...
la raíz cúbica
de "a" cuadrada
"b" cuadrada
y hemos terminado.
Ya hemos concluido la simplificación
y lo que voy a hacer ahora es,
dado que lo mencioné,
mostrarte la otra manera resolver esto,
y esto de aquí,
esta expresión de aquí,
la podemos escribir como
3 por "b" por "c",
todo elevado al cubo,
si estoy elevando al cubo cada uno de estos
y luego haciendo el producto,
esto es lo mismo que haga primero el producto
y luego eleve al cubo.
Estoy aplicando las propiedades
básicas de los exponentes,
así es que podemos escribir esto como,
la raíz cúbica
de tres "bc" elevado al cubo
por la raíz cúbica de
"a" cuadrada "b" cuadrada
y ahora,
extrayendo la raíz cúbica de aquí,
esto es claramente 3 por "b" por "c",
que multiplica a la raíz cúbica de
"a" cuadrada "b" cuadrada .
No identifique los términos con colores,
pues ya lo habíamos hecho eso aquí antes,
lo que quería mostrarte,
es que este otro camino que seguimos aquí
es una opción que es válida,
pues al final de cuentas
nos lleva a la misma respuesta.